so what's the current makeup of your
youtube verse at the moment you've got
multiple channels right
yeah the only one i really use at the
moment is a cad daily because i'm
currently setting up a website
um to do the same sort of things through
um and i'll start podcasting
other things after i've done that so i'm
just using this one at the moment
i got you and then you've still got the
like the old archived one the
grandfathered one
yeah yeah but um youtube have uh
quarantined it in some way
so well and i tested this the other day
on my new channel
i've got 300 000 subscribers and if i
put up a video within the first like
18 hours i'll have a million impressions
and some like 200 000 views um
and on my old channel i put it up and in
the first 18 hours i had about 100
000 impressions and that's got 900
that's got three times the subscriber
base
as my new channel and yet it will get
something like you know 10th of the
views
and it's crazy because my content isn't
i don't think markedly different my
audience still seems to be there
so it seems very much that the channel
itself has been throttled in some way so
i guess i just have to leave it i love
the idea of a quarantine channel
yeah well it happened to tommy robinson
as well and
it's it's happened to a few um but these
days are just outright taking them down
uh there have been um people who
excuse me um people who are more much
more extreme than me
who have been slowly
the the noose has been tightening and
now we've come
to conservative channels because all of
the
alt-right or anything like they're all
gone now they're on different platforms
so the noose is just growing tighter and
uh
you can see that people get targeted
before they get removed as well like
katie hopkins
and milo had their blue check marks
removed for their verification check
marks on twitter removed
which is weird because it just kind of
shows that it's not about verification
it's about privilege though isn't it i
mean milo and katie didn't stop
being milo and katie and no one thought
that they did
you know and since they they were public
figures of note you would think
that it would be important for the
public to easily identify them but
apparently not
there's a warning shot across the bow
then yeah i think uh
yeah it is and i think i mean facebook
actually has an active list
of uh i can't remember exactly what they
call the list but essentially it just
translates to wrong thinkers
uh i'm actually on it and a lot of other
people were on it who have been removed
i don't know how i still have facebook
presence but i mean i don't say anything
that's that's wrong you know crazy or
even bigoted
or anything like that you know i don't
even make jokes anymore um
because you can't have any fun on the
internet anymore apparently
but increasingly i've noticed that your
stuff appears to be
more and more you kind of treading it
sounds a little bit sometimes like you
are treading on ice
well we are there's very much a sword of
damocles hanging above our heads and
it's fallen a few times and cut me
already
so uh we've got the scars to prove it
yeah yeah
exactly i've got the scars to prove it
that's right um
so yeah i uh i just have to
have to be the thing that's really
interesting is
the way this all worked out because i i
can't help but notice that you're in
your house in your bedroom uh doing this
and
i began in very much the same way i just
had a one bedroom flat and i was just
doing it in my living room you know
because
at the time i was unemployed so i was
just like well i may as well
and it took off um now i have a
converted garage in my office but
uh you know i started in very much the
same position and
it's interesting how we're being held to
the same standards
as something like cnn or fox news
you know giant organizations with
hundreds of employees
and we're being held to the same
standards which really makes you wonder
why they need all of that to do their
jobs doesn't it
you know if it's so easy that just cut
you know guys in
in their homes can do as effective a job
then
maybe uh maybe there's a there's a veil
that they're hiding behind
this was a point that eric weinstein
made on joe rogan's podcast better than
i've heard anyone make it and what he
said was that
people refer to the mainstream media
now that's what the cnn the bbc's yeah
so on and so forth
corporate media hang on a second if
this podcast me and you joe rogan or me
and you if this gets
100 million views which would be great
uh but if this gets 100 million views
and cnn puts a video up and it gets 500
000 views
who's mainstream media now
now you can call them traditional media
traditional media is a
nice word but they don't want that
because mainstream's a signal
mainstream is we are the arbiters of
truth we are the ones
it is it what what we mean when we say
mainstream
isn't really the view counts and it
hasn't been for a while and that's why
we're being treated as
competitors to them but what they're
talking about is approved
these are the approved media the
approved gateways ratified ones
exactly the people and the thing is
because it is
all a system that interlocks you cannot
sorry you can understand why they would
want such a thing
because it puts them all essentially on
the same team when it comes to certain
issues
uh the for example the bbc they brag
about
how everyone still comes to the bbc when
they want to get you know the
coronavirus information it's like okay
that's true but you are also a
privileged
source because of your access the
politicians
make the platforms as much as the
platforms make the politicians
uh if politicians wanted they could just
refuse to do interviews with any of the
media
and just do interviews on their own
youtube channels using a smartphone or
something
you know they could say look here's the
questions i want to answer blah blah
blah
thanks very much and then the media
would have to extract from that and then
they would just be
just like anyone else but it's access
that they have and this is
it's a two-way street they there are
it's
from from my time dealing with all of
this and i've
met a few very interesting people in my
time it's very much about
who you know because there's no shortage
of people
there's a shortage of trust and so it's
about making
creating like webs of trust between
people and
and it's very and the thing is i don't
see how it could operate any other way
that's the problem uh because you've got
too many people who are pulling at you
i would say so i think it's probably
inevitable it's going to work that way
but yeah so
essentially when you're someone like me
and you come from it from the complete
outside you know i didn't i didn't have
any of this
um i can see why they hate us
you know there's some guy in his garage
some guy in his garage yeah yeah
and because we can say things they can't
say we can challenge narratives they
don't dare challenge
um and they'll punish us for it that's
what they're doing
[Music]